Have you seen all these protests
around the world supporting Palestine?
Even after these abhorrent attacks
by Hamas on Israeli civilians.
It's an important reminder
that the movement
for the liberation of Palestinians
is very different than this violent
terrorizing group called Hamas.
The vast majority of Palestinians
are not Hamas.
They simply want freedom
and dignity and autonomy.
And yet their land has been sliced up,
built on
and is under
constant control and surveillance
by Israeli military and citizens.
When I was reporting in the West Bank,
I saw that
this is also a form of violence.
It is a quieter
and less flashy
form of violence,
it doesn’t make the same kind of news,
but it is violence nonetheless.
And yet it in
no way justifies
what Hamas has done
in launching these attacks.
These protests remind us
that there is a bigger,
more legitimate movement at play here
one that should not be conflated
with Hamas
and their horrible actions
in the last few days.